miliband
do you think socialism remains an
important and evident labour party value
if so why and how
well i call democratic socialism that's
what's on our party carlin
yes is the answer because i think i
believe in a fairer more equal society
now
each generation of labor politicians
puts it into practice in their own
generation now what does it mean today
and it goes back to the question that
this lady asked which is what i see in
britain and you know this is the thing
that countries all around the world are
grappling with this is the central
question we face
are we going to be countries that work
for the richest and most powerful this
is what america is facing president
obama as well are we going to be a
country that just works for the richest
and most powerful or is everyone going
to get a fair shot
is you know is everyone going to play by
the same rules
if you're going to do the right thing go
out to work are you going to be able to
build a life for you and yourself and
your family lots of people are doubting
that in britain to the gentleman who
asked me whether i was too gloomy that's
why i think it sometimes might sound
that way because i think people are
asking hang on a minute this country was
supposed to work for me why doesn't it
work for me anymore i'm doing what
everyone tells me i should do so that's
what democratic socialism means a fair
more equal society making this country
work for working people again what do
you think lynn
i think that that needs to be revisited
those values within the labour party
currently okay it needs to be reaffirmed
we thought that it would you've got your
hands out there just here in the second
row you just wanted to ask a quick
follow-up question what's your name can
you just wait for the microphone there
we go you've got it